مثال على قيام شخص ما بالشيء الصحيح
في مواجهة التعصب
والجهل مرة أخرى في هذه اللحظة ، لا
أعرف ما إذا كان سيغير الأشخاص
الذين فعلوه أيضًا
ولكنهم يواجهون عواقب في الوقت
الحالي وهذا ما يحتاج الناس إلى فعله
بنسلفانيا rideshare driver james bode أو bodie ينشر على Facebook
لقاء أجراه مع العملاء المحتملين في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، انتشر الفيديو
منذ ذلك الحين ، شاهد
مرحبًا
[Music]
كما لو كنت تتحدث الإنجليزية ،
آسف ،
هذا غير مناسب
ما هو غير مناسب تمامًا إذا
لم يكن شخص ما  بيضاء تجلس في
المقعد ، ما هو الفرق
، هل أنت جاد ، قالت ، واو أنت
رجل أبيض ،
حسنًا ، لن أقوم برحلة يا
رفاق ، يمكنك الخروج
حقًا ، نعم ، هذا غير مناسب تمامًا.
لكمة
أنت ستهددني ، نعم ، هذا كل شيء على ما
يرام ، حسنًا ، لأنك يا رفاق
عنصريون ،
لا ، لا ، أنا أتصل برجال الشرطة عليك يا
رجل ، كل شيء على الكاميرا ، كل شيء على الكاميرا ،
لذا انظروا إلى بعض من
هذا  ربما لا ينبغي أن يتغلب على ذلك
لأنه وصف الرجل بأنه عاشق في
كلمة إلا أنه لم يقل
نوعًا ما من الكلمات التي يصعب تسميتها عندما
لا يمكنك في الواقع نطق الكلمة
الصحيحة التي تستجيب شركتك
للفيديو.  أنهم ممتنون للغاية
لجيمس لإغلاقه على الفور
لهذه الكراهية ودعم سياسات عدم
التسامح المناهضة للتمييز ،
وقد حاول فريقنا الوصول إلى
كل شخص رأيناه في هذا المقطع لم
نسمع عنه مرة أخرى في وقت يبدو فيه الكراهية في
بلدنا  إنه لأمر رائع
أن نتذكر أن هناك دائمًا
فرصة للوقوف
والقيام بالشيء الصحيح